le figaro live bienvenue en ce mercredi
30 septembre 2020 ravie de commencer la
journée avec vous il est 8h30 3 et on se
retrouve un peu tôt aujourd'hui il faut
le dire mais on se retrouve pas ce qu'un
événement s'est joué à cleveland dans
l'ohio aux etats-unis cette nuit le
premier des trois débats entre les deux
candidats à la présidentielle américaine
que vous voyez à l'image donald trump et
joe biden le républicain le démocrate
bien sûr alors vous dormiez certainement
en tout cas en france métropolitaine au
moment où où les joutes verbales ont eu
lieu sur le plateau vous apercevez
derrière moi pas de problème on va
rattraper ça on va débriefer et on va
prendre toutes vos questions sur le
figaro.fr sur notre chaîne twitch ainsi
que sur notre chaîne youtube un joueur
que vous êtes déjà nombreux bienvenue à
toutes et à tous deux experts nous
accompagne en ce mercredi matin pour
bien éclairer ce débat sur le fond et la
forme jean eric branaa tout d'abord
bonjour jean eric bien
du vous êtes maître de conférences à
l'université paris 2 spécialistes de la
politique américaine et puis vous êtes
l'auteur de la biographie de joe biden
qui sort le 7 octobre on va voir la
couverture de ce livre à paraître bien
dans quelques jours
c'est aux éditions nouveau monde
bienvenue aussi à christophe de vogue
sur figaro live christophe bonjour
bonjour vous êtes professeur agrégé
d'histoire à sciences po spécialiste de
rhétorique politique vous êtes également
président du conseil scientifique de la
fondapol la fondation pour l'innovation
politique
alors on va beaucoup parler de la forme
mais on ne va pas occulter font un bien
sûr concernant ce débat donald trump joe
biden on attend vos commentaires dans le
chat le figaro.fr twitch youtube
parlons d'abord de la forme puisque qui
dit donald trump dit évidemment débat
musclé jean eric branaa c'est ce qu'on
pouvait attendre et ce qui a eu lieu pas
mal de noms d'oiseaux un finalement dans
ces 90 minutes
alors au delà des noms d'oiseau on va on
va retenir quand même que c'était
effectivement traités stone est un
serpent de mâle alpha qui était sur le
plateau et qui s'affrontaient dans
l'autre
deux hommes nés dans les années 50 et
qui ait gagné 40 pardon et qui ont eu un
parcours de vie alors petit technique
avec vous jean eric on va j'attendais
qui est en même temps un train qui
parlait alors je laisser parler je vais
vous alors pardon on va on va baisser
leur tour sont en plateau alors qu'on
aperçoit chris wallace qui est le
journaliste de 72 ans qui a modéré on
peut le dire les débats qui a souvent
appelé au calme
gentlemen gentlemen générique pardon je
vous ai coupé vous
vié qui a eu pas mal de noms d'oiseaux
mais ça ne doivent pas non plus au delà
de ça ce qu'on va retenir la conclusion
même de tout le débat assez que donne
joe biden n'a pas été ce qu'on annonce
depuis maintenant un an qui est la
propagande de donald trump et qui est
repris à mon avis de façon un peu
paresseuse par beaucoup de commentateurs
à savoir que c'est un endormie qu'il est
sénile qu'il est mauvais des mateurs
écouter ce qu'on a vu sur scène c'est
exactement le contraire c'est un homme
politique de premier plan
très punchy ça fait cinquante ans qu'il
est en politique joe biden et il a quand
même gagné sa première victoire contre
un sénateur confirmé dans le delaware
c'était perdu d'avancé 18 ans il a été
le plus jeune sénateur de l'histoire des
états unis
il a regagné toutes ces élections haut
la main il a été président la commission
justice du sénat de la commission des
affaires étrangères du sénat
vice-président états unis vous savez un
homme pareil qui a même réussi à mettre
en échec
ronald reagan sur la nomination de
robert bork injuste la cour suprême qui
ressemble furieusement à la juge qui
vient d'être nommé par donald trump il
ya quelques jours
cet homme-là évidemment allait se
révéler tel qu'il est et c'est ça en
réalité qu'on va retenir de ce débat il
est pas là par hasard
il n'a pas gagné cette primaire par
défaut comme certains le pensent et il a
vraiment battus 27 candidats au parti
démocrate et est donc c'est vraiment pas
un candidat faible
cette introduction jean eric branaa
bonjour âgé dé bor bonjour du côté de
saint-etienne évidemment la loire est
avec nous ce matin dans le tchat sur
lefigaro.fr bonjour à jean-paul
également je vois d'ores et déjà des
questions si sur notre chaîne youtube
est ce que il y en a un qui a pris le
dessus nous demande jeu qu'il
une question pour vous christophe de
voogd est ce qu'il ya vraiment un
gagnant finalement dans ce dans ce débat
écoutez je serai un petit peu plus
modérées peut-être que jean-eric branaa
sur sur byden dans la mesure où il avait
fait une carrière exceptionnelle mais
qu'on peut pas toujours être et avoir
été
c'est à dire que il a aussi l'âge de ses
artères et il n'a quand même pas non
plus
absolument survolé ce débat cela dit là
où je suis d'accord tout à fait avec
jean eric branaa lé sait que le fait
qu'il ait résisté à trump et parfois
qu'il est contre boxer si j'ose dire
ce simple fait et pour lui suffisant
c'est à dire qu'il ne s'est en effet pas
du tout effondré il s'est même pas du
tout à aucun moment il n'a hésité on
peut dire que ce sable fait à mon avis
et c'est peut-être pour ça que trament
devenait de plus en plus agressif et
l'interrompent est de plus en plus ce
simple fait est suffisant pour son camp
dans la mesure où tout le monde le sait
il est quand même nettement en tête dans
les sondages
donc je crois que le fait de ne le fait
de ne pas perdre dans ce débat est déjà
un très gros avantage pour le candidat
démocrate
est ce qu'on peut dire christophe de voc
que sur le plan sur la forme sur ce plan
des joutes verbales notamment est-ce que
baden a été dans un premier temps dans
une position bien de deux boxeurs qui
prend les coups et est ce qu ensuite il
a rendu ses coûts à donald trump
j'ai trouvé qu'au début il était encore
un peu cher
qui ne le serait pas il était un petit
peu emprunté on le voyait qui lisait
beaucoup ses notes qu'il avait a
vraiment beaucoup travaillé alors je
dirais qu'ils ont eu tous les deux le
des fois vers ce bail d'alep est un peu
trop travailler trump clairement n'avait
pas assez travaillé il paraît que je
parle sous contrôle de jean-eric il
n'avait révisées si j'ose dire que deux
heures eh bien là c'est une grosse
erreur et comment j'ai appris ça je me
suis dit ça va pas bien forcément se
passer pour lui parce que on ne peut pas
avoir un débat même quand on a le style
trump on ne peut pas aborder un débat
avec deux heures de préparation et tous
ceux qui vous diront le contraire
vous trompons donc de ce point de vue là
peut-être un peu trop de préparation
mais baydan assez rapidement a pris le
rythme a répondu un peu cour de récré
c'est à dire sharp klein
ce qui est en fait à mon avis une bonne
chose pour parler abusé avec troc mais
ce qui est une bonne chose parce que
c'est le langage que trump comprend et
c'est le seul langage finalement qui
peut le calmer donc je dis en effet
comme un geek avec encore une fois un
peu plus de nuances parce que j'ai pas
eu l'impression de voir kennedy quand
même je n'ai pas eu l'impression de voir
obama et je pense que là c'est quand
même dû à son âge je pense quand même
que c'est plutôt un avantage maiden on
va voir justement un extrait avant de
vous redonner la parole monsieur de
prendre le les commentaires qui sont
déjà nombreux notamment sur notre chaîne
youtube on va voir un extrait qui résume
finalement là la tonalité un de ceux où
les deux candidats à la présidentielle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette pastille cet extrait monté par
mathilde serra de figaro live alors
espèce de clone est ce que vous avez à
fermer arrête de jacasser vous nous
parliez tous les deux jean eric branaa
christophe de voogd de candidats
d'expérience
est-ce que c'est digne ce qu'on vient
d'entendre convient de lire sur figaro
live jean-eric est-ce que c'est digne de
la fonction que ces deux hommes veulent
occuper aulas y avait rien d'indigné ont
été tendus dans un langage relâchés mais
fia c'est à des insultes en réalité on
est dans une rhétorique ouvrière et ça
tombe bien on est dans la le bas de la
respecte et on essaie de séduire les
ouvriers ont qu on leur parle c'est
assez clair c'est fait pour ça vous
savez juste avant le débat sur bayonne
avait twitté remettons les choses à leur
place et celui qui parle aux ouvriers
c'est moi effacer une petite pub qui
avait été fait et moi je suis de
scranton en pennsylvanie
alors que l'autre mais de park avenue
c'est à dire le pays des milliardaires
et donc il fallait le montrer qu'il
était ouvrier comme les autres il vient
de la banlieue il a répété plusieurs
fois pendant ce débat il a ce langage
parce que c'est le langage qui connaît
mais baida a toujours parlé comme ça
c'est pas quelque chose de nouveau non
plus les deux ont une rhétorique à ses
proches une façon de faire à ses proches
et ceux qu'on sépare en france aussi
c'est que ans dont quatre ans celui qui
a le plus attaqués donald trump aux
etats unis c'est joe biden et ça avait
commencé avec un discours assez serré
dans lequel il avait dit mais si j'avais
été au lycée avec lui je l'aurais pris
vers le gymnase pour le tabasser voyez
on était dans la dans laquelle chose à
peu près à part capable n'a pas parlé de
tabassage cette fois ci mais on était à
deux doigts une rhétorique assez proche
de celle de donald trump vous êtes
d'accord avec ces propos de jean eric
branaa vous christophe de voogd qui est
spécialiste de rhétorique politique oui
je suis assez d'accord enfin je pense
que baye donne peut-être ce emprunte un
peu plus le rôle et que je pense que
c'est plus naturel et si j'ose dire à 30
mais nous sommes et je crois que ces
deux candidats ça le montre très bien
nous charles lorsque christian salmon
vous savez le sociologue appelle l'ère
du clash c'est à dire on l'a vu arriver
aux états unis avec les débats entre il
a
et tram ou justement hillary clinton
était encore old school elle était
encore dans l'ère précédente où poser
des questions on y répondait et avec les
démocrates ont découvert que non
maintenant ça c'était un autre type de
rapports qui doivent avoir lieu et c'est
ce qu'on a vu hier tout à fait une
illustration de l'ère du clash
moi je suis un peu plus peut-être un peu
plus sévère je trouve que c'est c'est
pas forcément très bon signe et je
trouvais j'étais quand même très frustré
surtout moi qui ne suis pas un grand
spécialiste des états unis comme jean
eric branaa j'étais un peu j'étais un
peu frustré sur le fond quand même juste
une question quand même encore pour vous
christophe une question qui nous vient
de youtube avec mister code green qui
après avoir vu cet extrait nous demande
si c'est ça le parler direct américain
question c'est pour vous un jean eric
bayle et par la fed ce qui est
intéressant c'est ce qu'on appelle là
donc c'est rhétorique du clash
identifiés depuis très longtemps parce
que c'est pas tout à fait une invention
moderne ça existait dans la grèce
antique et donc la rhétorique est à
traiter ces sujets très tôt vous avez eu
par exemple on l'a vu mais alors en
permanence qu'on appelle l'argument de
l'homme de paille show management en
anglais c'est à dire on prête à l'autre
une attention ou une déclaration qu'il
n'a jamais eue
ils l'ont fait systématiquement dès le
début j'ai entendu trump accusé byden de
vouloir socialiser les états unis
hebeisen accusé trame de vouloir
supprimer l'assurance maladie je dis
bien supprimé 1
donc cette cette façon de faire tout de
suite nous plonge dans l'excès est
typique de cette rhétorique ou du coup
on va jamais traité véritablement les
positions des uns et des autres malgré
tous les efforts du modérateur que tout
le monde
incendies mais moi que j'ai trouvé qu'il
a fait ce qu'il a pu vu les
circonstances il a essayé à chaque fois
de revenir sur les vrais déclarations
sur les vrais chiffres
mais c'était très difficile avec deux
hommes qui avaient pris une stratégie de
l'extrême on peut dire alors avec le
style plus agressif de trump est plus
modérée le style mais sur le fond si
j'ose dire byden était lui aussi dans la
caricature
et justement l'objectif
bien de mettre en colère baden at il
réussi son objectif donald trump c'est
une question qui nous vient de youtube
jean-eric qu'est ce que vous en pensez
mais c'était l'objectif numéro un
on connaît les emportements de baden qui
a des moments par très rapidement jeu
juste une petite contradiction par
rapport à ce que vient de dire keystone
dans le jeu
hayden ne jouent pas leur rôle il est
comme ça il y un réellement il est il a
grandi à sprint mais ensuite il a fini
grandir à wilmington dans le delaware
c'est quelqu'un qui vient d'un milieu
très modeste et qui a et qui s'est
battue c'était un même bagarreur quand
il était jeune donc c'est vraiment sa
nature profonde il est ainsi il parle
ainsi
et donc il ya ce côté tempérament on
pourrait dire latin alors qu'ils les
irlandais c'est peut-être son sang
français puisqu'il a dans robin est d
origine huguenote mais il il est
réellement comme ça donc on a eu
effectivement un maiden en face de nous
qui était vrai ça c'était vraiment très
intéressant je trouve
j'ai perdu le reste de la question par
bancaire oui en fait l'objectif était de
mettre byden en colère nous dit un
internaute sur ie mais c'est sérieux et
en relais de jeter il fait réussie est
en réalité c'est ce que voulait faire
trump parce que la grosse difficulté
avec la pandémie c'est que by john s'est
renforcé dans un rôle qu'il n'avait pas
tant que ça en début de campagne qui
était d'être le grand sage le l'homme
pose est qui qui prend de la hauteur et
il fallait donc le faire revenir dans
son naturel donc il ya beaucoup de
provocation de la part du trump ça c'est
trop vu en réalité ça a commencé trop
tôt peut-être qu'il avait fait
uniquement sur scène ça aurait mieux
marché et ce côté là le manque de
préparation qui était évoqué tout à
l'heure on voit bien ça marche pas avec
maiden il faut être effectivement plus
carré pour une présidentielle
mais effectivement c'est l'échec
flagrant de trunks moi je dirais puisque
j'ai pas répondu à la question de
valeurs plus que est-ce que maidana
gagner moi je dirais que trump a perdu
c'est lui qui perce ce débat c'est lui
qui effectivement n'est pas préparée et
à une mauvaise stratégie
la stratégie de l'interruption constante
pour empêcher une buydens
et sur le fond n'a même pas fonctionné
puisque maiden a même réussi à faire
passer des éléments de son programme en
tout cas les titres ce qui permet
ensuite aux gens d'aller chercher
davantage une question encore à nouveau
un sur youtube à quand le prochain débat
15 octobre pour le deuxième débat ce
sera à miami en floride il y en aura un
troisième le 22 octobre
du côté de nashville dans le tennessee
justement tient sur le plan de la
rhétorique politique du coup christophe
de voogd éclairez nous cette façon de
couper en permanence son adversaire son
concurrent qu'est ce que ça dit du
candidat donald trump
mais c'est justement typiquement alors
là l'interruption en rhétorique c'est
bien connu c'est très utilisé on le voit
en france certains partis de pratiques
plus que d'autres et ce quelque chose
c'est une arme anti faut pas abuser
pourquoi parce que si vous en faites
beaucoup vous allez d'abord agacé le les
auditeurs qui veulent écouter ce que
baye donne à dire vous agace et surtout
le modérateur qui est intervenu 150 fois
pour dire à trump mais laissez le parler
or le modérateur n'est pas véritablement
de l'extrême gauche n'est ce pas jean
eric branaa donc il a été il a été
d'ailleurs vif très gentleman il a dit
mais laissez le parler donc vous mais
vous prenez à témoin de l'audience que
trump violent les règles du débat
donc c'est pas bon du tout pour son étau
c'est-à-dire pour son apparence auprès
du public
et encore une fois je pense là on ne
sachant que ça tu es tout à fait
d'accord c'est l'absence de préparation
trump et ans j'avais overcome fedon
saiem à nancy passionne toute la nuit et
ayant trop confiance en lui même il a dû
dire à ses conseillers je sais comment
faire
j'ai comme une partie de golf pour moi
je vais y arriver
et en fait il a un peu sous-estimé
l'adversaire cela dit byden tel qu'en
lui-même jeunes gens seraient un petit
peu parce que les face caméra je parle
pour des américains
c'était quand même très sollicités très
préparée et j'étais moi j'aurais été
america j'aurais pas été très convaincu
avec cette véritablement post cette
posture très claire d'éviter trunk et de
parler à l'amérique profonde
je crois que là il y avait aussi un
petit peu
d'artificialité en tout cas
l'interruption permanente
il avait très peu avait fait un peu avec
hillary clinton mais pas tout le temps
et surtout ce qui ne l'avait pas dans
ceux dans ceux du premier débat par
rapport à il arrive c'est qu'elle
évidemment qu'il a manqué de répartie la
force de tram quand il est en forme
1 c'est de trouver la petite phrase qui
dit vraiment kick ass l'autre comme par
exemple quand ils disent à hillary
clinton
je vais vous mettre en taule et c est ça
hier il n'a pas trouvé ce qui veut dire
que encore une fois il n'avait pas assez
préparés maintien justement une question
va basculer sur vous jean eric branaa
une question qui nous vient de youtube
de romain bonjour à vous romain est ce
qui a eu des défaillances d'un ou des
candidats lors de questions qu'il aurait
ou les auraient mis en difficulté ah oui
clairement alors c'est la première
défaillance concernant donald trump
c'est toute la partie sur la santé
franchement il a été vraiment pas bon là
dessus et il s'est fait manger par
bayonne qui a pu développer toute cette
partie on arrivait sur la queue vide et
c'est à ce moment là que train de semer
interrompre vraiment beaucoup parce
qu'il sait qu'il est en danger
clairement deux cent mille morts
c'est à dire qu'il ya des gens qui
auraient la télé en disant je sois j'ai
perdu quelqu'un dans la famille soit je
connais quelqu'un qui a perdu
il faut donc absolument noyer le poisson
quand on travaille ou quoi mais ensuite
ils remontent au moment de l'économie
parce que c'est ça c'est son point fort
et il personne ne songe à dire que trump
a été mauvais sur l'économie depuis six
mois il n'y peut rien et là dessus les
gens aiment évidemment sont dans la
bienveillance et c'est un peu normal
puisque il n'y est pour rien par la
suite c'est plutôt maiden qui a une
vraie défaillance et elle est due
d'ailleurs un christ palace c'est ce qui
montre même s'il va être
vilipendé par le contre un peuple avoir
beaucoup arrêter leur candidat il pose
quand même une question très difficile à
bayonne en lui demandant mais qu'est ce
que vous avez fait vis-à-vis des
manifestations importantes et vous
appelez le maire il faut appeler le le
gouverneur et la balle donner une
réponse qui est pas bonne
non je n'ai pas de fonction actuellement
donc je n'avais pas le faire alors qu'il
est quand même le candidat à la
présidence des états unis donc à ce
titre n'a déjà il pouvait leur passer un
petit coup de fil
et puis les connais très bien ça ça
c'est une vraie difficulté où on voit
donnant vraiment en difficulté à ce
moment là et puis la grosse grosse
défaillance de trump c'est dans le
cinquième
la cinquième phase insisté sur
l'environnement où là il perd pied c'est
c'est un ko technique je veux dire
bailon parle tout seul et il parle à ce
moment-là il déroule son programme
puisque on le laisse parler avait il y
va et il commence à expliquer tout ce
qu'il veut faire et pas faire ça lui
permet même de corriger une
contre-vérité qui est circuit beaucoup
dans les réseaux train piste à savoir
qu'il est contre la fracture qu'il est
contre la fracturation hydraulique
et comme on est juste à côté la
pennsylvanie il est si important dans
cet état et que la passive annie est si
importante dans la présidentielle
eh bien il peut placer très clairement
je laisserai la fracturation hydraulique
que dans cet état ça c'est vraiment un
point fort pour lui voilà notre homme
catastrophique sur le climat c'est ce
que vous avez posté en regardant le
débat cette nuit sur votre compte
twitter jean eric branaa en plus aigus
7,7 parmi ces colis bcc noms d'oiseaux
donald trump a accusé joe biden d'être
en gros la marionnette de la gauche
radicale et pourtant que je baille donne
lui il affirmé qu'il ne soutenait pas le
ce que l'on appelle le green new deal
c'est un plan démocrate avancée par
parallèle gauche sur le climat est ce
que vous pouvez nous parler un peu de ce
plan jean eric oui absolument
il ya quand même un élément important
qui est repris de grignoter cette nuit
quand on qu'on n'avait pas il explique
que le zéro carbone et va essayer de
l'atteindre d'ici 2035 dont grande
surprise puisque c'était 2050 jusqu'à
maintenant dans son programme donc il
avance le green new deal lui le proposer
à 2030 ouailles on est très très près
quand même maintenant donc c'est un plan
qui vise à éliminer le fossile et
justement il a pu expliquer tout cela il
indique par exemple s'il soutenait la
fracturation hydraulique comme je le
disais c'est il est plus possible
aujourd'hui de le développer
donc on le soutient parce que c'est là
mais on va le faire disparaître
pareil pour le charbon impossibles un
non d'ouvrir de nouvelles mines ça ils
l'ont repas mais on va pas éliminer
celles qui existent donc il s'agissait
ma série donne en fait du compromis en
réalité c'est l'histoire de sa vie c'est
jeu je vous tends la main en disant je
vais protéger les emplois pour ceux qui
sont là mais en même temps excusez moi
mais la planète va mal donc il va
falloir trouver une solution et être un
peu plus dynamiques sur cette question
là ça c'était important et il l'a fait
ça sur cette question il l'a fait
également sur la santé on a et le même
phénomène
il a attaqué la même façon par train en
début de débat sur la santé et trump
l'accusent de faire du socialisme et là
il y répond excusez moi mais c'est moi
le candidat démocrate voulaient serait
maître de mon programme est dû décider
ce que j'y mets dedans c'était une très
bonne répartie je trouve mais je sais
pas ce qu'ils doivent à partager cet
avis là mais j'ai trouvé cette cette
pirouette de dire bah laissez moi écrire
moi même genre vous faites effectif trop
longtemps parce que vous raconter mon
programme à ma place alors vous l'aurez
compris on parle du fond parce que c'est
vrai que quand on écoute pas mal de
médias ce matin dans l'impression de
résumer ce débat aux noms d'oiseaux qui
ont fusé et aux insultes et aux voilà au
débat musclé qui a eu lieu cette nuit et
quand même beaucoup de choses de dites
sur sur sur le fond concernant la santé
l'épidémie de kovy de 10,9 dont vous
parliez à l'instant jean eric branaa est
là cette fois je me tourne vers vous
christophe devaux qu'est ce que joe
biden
au delà du bilan de donald trump s'est
montré comme un potentiel président
solide face à la suite de cette pandémie
alors globalement et part dans la chute
je ne suis moi je ne suis pas
complètement convaincu encore et je
pense que c'est encore une fois très
largement dû à la fatigue
je pense que baye donne n'a pas
complètement convaincu alors il a très
bien répondu en effet en disant c'est
mon programme mais sur le col vide quand
même présente et rome comme quasiment
celui qui avait introduit le colis deux
états unis où je les trouvais très
caricatural si on écoutait et ries
parlait aux yeux de l'amérique s'était
vraiment il a fait beaucoup de pathos
sur ce thème comme si trump et là
vraiment il a accusé tron des coupables
c'était très clair il est même dit vous
êtes responsable de la mort de deux cent
mille personnes
là je crois qu'il a été lui excessif
époux à mon avis pas très convaincant
alors que sur ce sujet c'était assez
facile si j'ose dire de se faire trump
plus je dirais de façon plus crédible
sur le climat il a été assez bon mais je
trouve qu'il a mis beaucoup de temps à
bien ce prêt à bien se positionner sur
le le green deal s'ils étaient pour ou
contre il fallait attendre longtemps il
a fallu attendre une question du
journaliste pour qu'il dise non je
reprends pas l'intégralité du du green
deal du parti démocrate
donc j'ai trouvé moi moins convaincant
que ce que vous dites même si là je suis
d'accord avec vous sur cette question
trump était très mauvais et je dirais
que brydon a été moins mauvais pardon
qu'il sait que je vous interromps mais
sur cette question du climat est ce
qu'on a bien compris
nous spectateurs américains aux
spectateurs français qui à la traduction
est ce qu'on a bien compris comment joe
biden comptes mails et l'environnement
et l'économie
moi je trouve que justement il n'est pas
n'a pas été convaincant là dessus c'est
à dire c'est à dire quand jean eric a
retracé sa démonstration
on a même senti l'ambiguïté c'est à dire
est ce qu est ce qu il fait finalement
de tout ce qui existe puisqu'il veut dès
2035 c'est-à-dire dans 15 ans en avoir
fini avec tout il a dit zéro carbone il
a même je crois qu il a dit zéro énergie
parce que c'est ça aussi des fois le
problème chez chez bailon c'est qu'elle
ait confusion sur les mots en tout cas
cette cet objectif extrêmement ambitieux
à mon avis moi je on attendra les autres
débats et les explications du parti
démocrate
à mon avis là il ya quand même il a
plutôt ouvert une question que traiter
le sujet et les secteurs notamment les
ouvriers qui lui sont si chers et qui
sont quand même un très important dans
le vote du mois prochain
le risque c'est quand même que les
ouvriers des secteurs traditionnels
demeurent inquiets devant programme
démocrate
merci en tout cas à toutes et à tous
d'être avec nous ce matin sur figaro
live sur lefigaro.fr sur tweets sur
youtube il ya beaucoup de questions on
va les prendre au fur et à mesure vous
parliez du pathos tout à l'heure
christophe de voogd je vois un
commentaire sur lefigaro.fr momo qui
nous dit est hausse logos pathos les
trois ressorts de la rhétorique que
trump ne maîtrise pas qu'est ce que on
va s'arrêter sur ce commentaire
qu'est ce que vous en pensez christophe
alors c'est sûr que là c'est typique de
l'ère du clash on n'a pas beaucoup de
droit au logo c'est à dire au discours
rationnel et aux chiffres vrai l'aja
l'erika totalement raison sur la
caricature du programme écologiste par
tram quand il dit que ça va coûter 100
mille milliards de dollars enfin
pourquoi pas 100 mille milliards de
milliards enfin je veux dire on est on
est dans la guerre des étoiles là on est
plus en politique
l'ethos non justement dans l'ère du
clash qui compte c'est plus que jamais
les taux c'est à dire là on vote pour un
personnage on voit que pour un
personnage dont donc trump la force la
simplicité l'anticonformisme by donne
l'expérience la sincérité etc
on va donc essayer de se profiler
puisque finalement on est une tête
d'affiche et on est au contraire
totalement dans l'ethos c'est à dire on
veut être celui auquel les gens adhèrent
c'est pour ça qu'ils y avait tant de
critiques sur vous l'avez vu sur des
attaques personnelles puisque on essaie
de détruire les tos de l'autre et on
essaye de mettre en valeur le sien
propre
on a beaucoup de commentaires aussi je
vois celui de vincent sur lefigaro.fr je
vois celui de marion sur notre chaîne
youtube
beaucoup de commentaires qui concerne
l'âge de joe biden est ce que on va dire
si je veux si je prends la tonalité des
commentaires qui nous arrive est ce que
il s'est pas montré trop vieux ou en
tout cas moins est ce qu'il a réussi à
se montrer moins âgée que son âge sur le
papier jan erik john dans ce débat
écoutez moi je les trop vieux tous les
deux 5 à 77 ans les notes 74 ans que je
vais pas vous dire que ce sont des
perdreaux de l'année
effectivement c'est quelque chose que je
répète depuis le début de la campagne il
ya un ange annonçait que brydon elle est
gagnée dans un livre et je disais ça
peut être le président le plus
de l'histoire des états unis c'était
évident mais si c'est pas lui ça aurait
été trop puisqu'il aurait été aussi plus
vieux président des états unis
c'était une réalité aujourd'hui alors le
pourquoi
c'est ça la vraie question le
renouvellement politique est une vraie
question quand même c'est plutôt ça qui
est posée dans cette question là et joe
biden ya répondu que dans la campagne
dont dix ans qui voulait être un pont
entre deux générations entre le monde
d'avant et le monde après je trouve que
l'image est très belle parce qu'on est
effectivement au milieu d'un pont et ce
qui est encore plus beau et plus
intéressant c'est le prochain débat qui
va avoir lieu entre les vice-présidents
parce que là pour le coup on va avoir
deux amériques représenté avec deux
personnes quasiment du même âge ont le
coût est beaucoup plus jeune
mais l'un my peines qui va représenter
une amérique plus du passé conservatrice
est là avec de fortes valeurs
conservatrices planté dans la terre
américaine
et de l'autre côté une amérique qui veut
aller de l'avant vers le futur et et
diversifiées comme la crise et donc ça
va être très intéressant beaucoup plus
intéressant je pense qu'encore
d'assister à ce débat parce que le le
choc entre les deux amériques va être là
pour pour trump et hebeisen c'est une
fin de course
donc effectivement ils sont très vieux
on a pas mal de commentaires qui nous
parviennent toujours sur lefigaro.fr
surtout sur youtube merci d'être avec
nous ce matin alors des avis lyvan à qui
nous dit baye donne était clairement
moins ridicule que trump
on a pas mal de questions aussi sur sur
le débat tient question pour vous jean
eric romain qui nous demande si ben
hayden a dit ce qu'il aurait fait ou ce
qu'ils auraient amélioré s'il avait été
au gouvernement pendant cette première
partie de la pandémie de kobe de 19
quelle mesure aurait t'il prise oui
alors il est passé très rapidement parce
qu'il s'est fait beaucoup interrompre de
la parlais tout à l'heure
cette fameuse technique du crash il
fallait surtout pas le laisser parler
mais il a fait beaucoup pendant la
campagne il
fait dès le départ d'abord une
correction il n'a jamais dit que tout
simple et est responsable il a de même
c'est le premier homme politique aux
etats-unis qui a dit que trump n'était
pas responsable et que la pandémie était
tombé sur les états unis
en revanche il dit et répète que trump
n'a pas pris les bonnes décisions et ces
décisions avaient été dans ses mains
puisque c'est lui qui avait déclaré un
état d'urgence le 18 mars de cette année
qui a qui a très bien commencé
la chaîne en en pardon je faisais perdu
qui a très bien commencé en fermant les
frontières avec l'europe
il fallait le faire il était même
attaqué là dessus on disait que c'est du
nationalisme alors c'était du sanitaire
et c'est là dessus il est monté à 50 %
de bonnes opinions parce que les
américains ont suivi et juste derrière
les décisions c'était quoi bien c'était
de d'appliquer cet état d'urgence donc
c'était de réquisitionner les usines de
faire fabriquer des respirateurs tout de
suite de faire fabriquer des masques dû
réquisitionner les hôpitaux de d'envoyer
l'armée dans différents états il l'a
fait à new york à los angeles mais ça
s'est arrêté là c'était d'interdire les
vols en avion parce que le virus a
circulé de façon incroyable donné un
autre pendant deux mois avant qu'on
réalise que il passait avec les
passagers qui continuaient à circuler
c'était de déclarer un confinement
peut-être partiellement tout cas il
fallait qu'il soit présidentielle et
fédéral tout ça c'était dans ses mains
il ne l'a pas fait ce qui a créé un vrai
chaos parce que les gouverneurs ont dû
agir par eux mêmes et où certains ont
voulu le faire d'autres pas là on rentre
dans la division classique aux états
unis avec les républicains qui ne
veulent pas agir en tant qu état
providence qui intervient dans la vie
des gens donc ils se sont arc boutés sur
leurs positions et c'est normal c'est
leur position
les démocrates ont pensé qu'il fallait
intervenir et c'est là où il ya un
hiatus parce qu'on était dans une vraie
crise sanitaire jeu j'ai dit plusieurs
fois que site rome avait une autre
attitude qui avait poursuivi ce lèche le
début aujourd'hui on dirait que c'est un
grand président histoire et réélu
triomphalement le 3 mai c'est ça qui
fait en réalité les grands présidents ce
sont les crises et c'est en les crises
qu'on se révèle qu'on se révèle pas et
c'est là où on a vu que
c'est un marchand c'est un certainement
très bon commerçant mais ce n'est pas un
gestionnaire de crise grave et en tout
cas pas ses haltères pour pour ces
précisions et jean-eric continué
d'aborder le fond est toujours sur le
figaro.fr sur tweets sur youtube fait un
petit détour sur twitch pour saluer la
chaîne ostpolitik qui a lancé un raid
chez nous a écoutés merci et bienvenue à
toutes et à tous je vois is enyele clé
ban hassan id le bg du 75 authority
n'hésitez pas si vous avez des questions
sur le débat de cette nuit on est là
pour pour y répondre
un débat qui a commencé sur le fond par
et bien les les comment dire l'actualité
autour de la cour suprême
cette nomination qui a eu lieu ces
derniers jours à mi koné barrette qui va
donc remplacer ruth bader ginsburg qui
est décédé la doyenne il y a il y a
quelques jours
jean-eric est-ce que s'était fixé de
commencer là dessus où ce sont les
candidats qui ont décidé de
d'aborder le sujet à ce sujet pour
débuter le débat non non le planning
c'est chris walas qu'il a mis en place
et qui a décidé du découpage et m
moi j'ai eu l'occasion d'écrire un
article ce matin qu'ils ont bien fait de
commencer par cette question parce que
on s'écoutait encore un tout petit peu à
ce moment là donc on a pu en entendre
parler et c'était nécessaire
alors chacun a pu dire deux trois
phrases avant qu'ils commencent à se
couper de tous les côtés ce qu'on va
retenir c'est que bayonne a expliqué que
c'était pas bien parce qu'on était déjà
dans un processus de vote et qu'il
fallait laisser voter les américains
mais travail raison de répondre qu'il
est élu pour quatre ans puisqu'il est
lui jusqu'au 20 janvier à midi et qu' il
est tout à fait légitime à nommer un
juge même si ça choque certains y
mettent de l'éthique la constitution n'a
pas d'éthique la question c'est une loi
est la loi dit que le président nomme le
juge donc il nomme le juge ou la juge en
l'espèce et et le sénat doit confirmer
c'est son rôle c'est leur rôle à tous
qu'ils sont chacun vraiment dans leur
rôle donc il n'y avait vraiment rien de
choquant mais by john a été malin
puisque c'était pas ça qu'il voulait
défendre il voulait expliquer qu'en
nommant sept juges où on mettait en
danger l'obamacare et donc ça lui
permettait de faire sa pirouette pour
attaquer tout de suite sur la santé
d'ailleurs voilà ça a essayé de
l'arrêter à un moment dix ans et la
prochaine question mais mais là on voit
bien que banalité vie n'est qu'une
stratégie et sa fameuse préparation en
préparation on parlait tout à l'heure il
hayden avait des tas de route pour
essayer de repartir
c'est un vrai renard et moi ça hein je
vais déconner tout de suite bien sûr
comme d'autres wallace aussi puisqu'en
il a essayé de l'arrêter et trump
également puisque c'est là où il s'est
mis en branle très rapidement pour le
bloquer je vois des commentaires des
réactions qui continuent d'arriver à la
parole à vous dans quelques instants
christophe de voogd tous pour mad qui
nous dit débat horrible caricature du
dialogue de sourds tiens je voudrais
votre avis là-dessus christophe de vox
vous qui êtes spécialiste en rhétorique
politique caricature du dialogue de
sourds est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ce commentaire qui nous vient de
twitch à tout à fait nous sommes nous
vivons dans l'ère du clash c'est le
dialogue de sourds mais n'oublions quand
même pas que ce genre de débat tout
débat de ce genre
même quand ils étaient très polis et
jean-eric n'étaient pas nés mais je me
souviens il a certainement vu le débat
dans le débat entre nixon et et kennedy
par exemple où on est on idée d'une
politesse infinie même si et sur le fond
c'était beaucoup plus intéressant mais
dans cette n'oublions pas que par
définition
trump n'essaye pas de convaincre baden
ni byden essaie de convaincre trump donc
le dialogue de sourds il est normal dans
une campagne
on essaie de convaincre celui qui n'est
pas sur le plateau c'est à dire les
lecteurs donc n'oubliez jamais ça que
que peu importe finalement ce qui se
passe entre les deux hommes ce qui
compte c'est ce que va en penser les
lecteurs et donc le dialogue de sourd
peut influer sur les lecteurs s'ils
estiment que l'un des deux protagonistes
est responsable du blocage de la
communication donc ça c'est un point
important sur sur la question de de la
cour suprême devrait revenir un petit
peu à ce qu'a dit sur ce qu'a dit jean
eric branaa en lui donnant totalement
raison avec justement là la preuve là
parce que trump avait un point fort sur
cette question il pouvait jouer à fond
sur la constitution et il pouvait jouer
si à fond sur autre chose qu'il faut
aussi rappeler et que lui n'a pas
rappelé c'est qu'en 2016 les démocrates
avaient plaidé pour un remplacement
rapide
la juge de la cour suprême et parmi les
démocrates un certain joe biden et ce
qui m'a frappé dans tout le débat c'est
que trois pneus y en pas préparé n'a pas
utilisé les contradictions des
démocrates alors qu'abidal ayant bien
préparé a toujours mis en valeur les
contradictions de tram et l'âge à la
contradiction surtout dans l'ère du
clash c'est quelque chose de fondamental
si vous montrez que l'autre se contredit
il est disqualifié
trump n'a même pas eu la même pas
travailler pour justement montrer quel
point les démocrates sur ce sujet était
pas bon et là il aurait pu marquer un
point d'entrée ce qu'il n'a pas fait et
je suis bien d'accord avec cette
remarque en parenthèse on rappelle juste
que la cour suprême aux états unis un
ses skis au sommet du pouvoir judiciaire
on a mis neuf juges qui sont nommés à
vie et désormais on sait bien ça jean
eric branaa on a
si cette nomination est confirmée un
celle d'amis connaît barrette on a
désormais six juges à tendance
conservatrice et trois démocrates
c'est ça alors ça a l'air de faire peur
comme ça le mot conservateurs contre le
regarde de france c'est assez amusant
parce que en réalité et mitonné par est
assis dans une excellente une française
puisqu'elle appliquer exactement le tord
à la française c'est à dire une lecture
rigoriste du droit en interprétant pas
les textes les juges en france sont
censées s'il ya l'interprétation renvoyé
sur le parlement pour interprétation et
c'est ce que fait nico n'y paraît
mais au mot près pour elle s'il ya un
mot près la place de l'autre elles
disqualifient elle dit non vous n'aviez
pas le droit de le faire et donc elle
elle n'arrête pas de donner des mauvais
points à ses collègues en expliquant qu
ils sont pas très bons mais au-delà de
ça alors c'est plus sur ces idées
sociales ou sociétales que ça se joue
puisque évidemment les conséquences sont
là elles sont sur l'interprétation sur
le droit à la vie sur l'immigration sur
la santé sur la peine de mort le corps
des armes enfin toutes ces questions qui
qui pose problème et font débat
renvoyons le quand même à sa réalité ce
débat là normalement il a sa place au
congrès et non pas à la cour suprême est
en réalité on a affaire à une faillite
du congrès qui n'est pas en capacité de
porter ce débat de le défendre et de le
construire
donc dans quand on regarde la société
américaine encore faisant porter poids
très lourd aujourd'hui à la cour suprême
au zoo où ça va être l'horreur
on pourrait aussi leur tournée en disant
mais messieurs laisse mesdames et
sénateurs et messieurs mais l'ami
représentants c'est d'abord votre boulot
que de faire avancer tout ça en france
on a des grands noms on à badinter pour
la peine de mort de simone veil pour
l'avortement voyez il ya eu des débats
lourd difficile souvent contre l'opinion
et qui ont été menées de manière
politique et politicienne et volontaire
voilà ça c'est pour se débattre pour
l'élargir un petit peu là où il est moi
aussi j'ai trouvé que trump a été très
mauvais ne pas avancer toutes ces
espèces les arguments ne pas se mettre
aussi les conservateurs son côté en
insistant pas sur le fait qu'il avait
porté le programme des conservateurs
jusqu'au bout qu'il avait mis des juges
on n'a rien entendu tous alors qu'il
avait un boulevard devant lui et il a
préféré faire de l'obstruction à bayonne
alors que s'il avait lui
avancer ses propres idées à mon avis
sortait beaucoup plus gagnant de cinéma
il a fait de l'obstruction à baden vous
nous dit jean eric branaa et d'un autre
côté on aille ago qui nous dit sur
lefigaro.fr by donne dix ans chez knopf
la ferme à trump est ce vraiment la
tenue d'un candidat à la présidence de
la première puissance du monde
c'est une question pour vous christophe
de voogd alors moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec là je dirais la proche de
fondamental de jean-eric sur la question
de nous ne sommes pas en france
nous sommes aux états unis
quand elle arrivait à le comprendre la
même faute est faite de l'autre côté
c'est à dire qu'ils interprètent les
situations française en terme américains
nous nous devons bien comprendre que ça
ne fonctionne pas comme chez nous et
notamment genre et qu'elle lui rappeler
sur la question le rapport politique
droit alors il faut noter quand même que
en france on évolue un peu dans le sens
américain
puisqu'on attend de plus en plus
aujourd'hui que ce soit le conseil
constitutionnel ou le conseil d'état on
le voit bien avec l'aco vide que qui
interviennent ce qui veut dire qu'il ya
une juridication comme on dit comme
disent les politistes une juridication
de la vie démocratique dans tous nos
pays les américains étant très en avance
sur nous à cause de la place du droit
notamment en matière d'avortement qui
était si je me souviens bien c'était
décidé à 73 par la cour suprême ça alors
que nous nous faisions des lois cette
époque
voilà voilà la grande différence donc
les américains en sont plus cash que
nous dans le langage politique
donc ils ont un degré de tolérance et
d'acceptation chat d'apnée pas n'est pas
une insulte les gens eric lui rappelait
absolument catastrophique
c'était donc d'autre part à côté encore
une fois qu'ils sont plutôt cour de
récré ils sont plutôt comme dirait 30
pardon conversation de vestiaire c'est à
dire ce langage que les américains et
notamment l'audience qu'ils vivent tous
les deux là je suis entièrement d'accord
c'est à dire l'audience populaire parce
que beaucoup de choses vont se jouer là
sur l'audience ouvrière sur les classes
populaires ne peut comprendre ce qui est
plus pénible est encore une fois pour
tout le monde c'est le rythme du débat
son côté saccadé et le fait qu'on ne
peut jamais allé au fond là en effet
c'est un problème démocratique mais j'ai
bien peur que l'amérique ne
plus maintenant le chaque pays dans ce
plat en vrai c'était plus à ce débat ce
secteur plutôt qu'un vrai débat d'idées
je la trouve que nous dit à irin sur
twitter on a pas mal de questions aussi
sur celui que vous appelez depuis tout à
l'heure le modérateur qui est en fait
chris wallace journaliste de fox news de
72 ans qui a modéré les débats chris
wallace un journaliste connu comme étant
impartial de fox news une chaîne plutôt
pro trump c'est ce que nous dit craag
hatton sur twitch et puis on a toujours
sur twitter une autre question celle de
séverine qui nous demande s'il a bien
modérer les débats où ils couinent de
larbitre finalement j'en ai fait moi je
les trouvais g extraordinaire mais c'est
un journaliste qui est qui est très
droit
on sait pas trop le placer en réalité il
est plutôt proche du parti démocrate
tout en laissant à foxnews comme ça ça
va mettre tout le monde d'accord
mais surtout il s'est adressé encore une
fois je l'évoquais tout à l'heure avec
le même sérieux et la même
intransigeance aux deux candidats et ça
c'était très très plaisant alors c'est
vrai qu'il a réagi à ces coupures
incessantes parce que ça a perturbé le
cours de son organisation et c'est bien
normal
il a répété il est l arbitre donc il
fallait qu'il joue son rôle mais on la
pente ont dû intervenir
outre mesure même si trois caddies un
moment et j'ai déjà passé en débattre
avec vous ce qui était aussi une formule
d'ailleurs il a placé trop tôt à mon
avis parce qu'on était encore au tout
début du débat il aurait peut-être dû
attendre un peu pour que sa porte
réellement et surtout que ce n'était pas
vrai on l'a vu dans la suite
mais il avait surtout le rappel de son
interview d'hier un mois et demi sur la
cabine dans laquelle chris wallace
l'avait remis en question avec tous ces
chiffres et ces faux chiffres en le
disant mais vous pouvez pas faire ça et
pour président c'est trop grave
beaucoup beaucoup commenté cette
interview parce que effectivement elle
avait choqué pas mal de gens on va on va
encore parler un des sujets de fond joie
qui a pas mal de questions sur tiens on
va prendre question de youtube celle du
logo ce qu'ils nous disent qu'ils aient
eu un échange
s'agissant de blm du mouvement black
live matters est ce que ça a été abordée
ça a été abordée ça faisait partie des
thèmes ça jean eric branaa ah oui oui eh
bien oui pardon par contre les stades
suis entré non non je
c'était absolument aborder vers la fin
du débat au moment de la question du de
ce que les américains appellent law and
order et la question du racisme
je trouve que là sur le sur la question
du logo and order on y reviendra la
banda n'était quand même pas à l'aise
faut bien le dire et c'est normal parce
que les démocrates sont pas très à
l'aise là dessus je vois je suis tout à
fait d'accord sur la question du
modérateur
comme quoi il peut y avoir des choses
objectives dans un débat il a été
vraiment j'aurais pas aimé être à sa
place et tous les journalistes ou aux
commentateurs qui le critiquent j'aime
j'aurais bien aimé les voir il est resté
absolument serein ferme
je n'ai jamais vu personne jusqu'à
présent arrivant à faire taire trump et
lui arrive
ce qui est très exceptionnel et je le
trouvais il a vraiment cherché à chaque
fois qu'il avait une question difficile
pour l'un avoir une question difficile
pour l'autre donc pour moi je crois que
il est si quelqu'un n'est pas
responsable de la tenue de ce débat
c'est bien lui et moi je m'étonne même
qu'il ait réussi à aborder tous ces
sujets alors que trump avait une
stratégie du chaos
visiblement je voudrais ajouter si vous
permettez à propose de blackwater
en réalité en train de tendre un peu sur
un os avec hayden sur cette question là
parce que le spécialiste de du
sécuritaire au parti démocrate sebaï
donne c'est lui qui a fait une loi avec
strom sommes donc le le leader du parti
républicain en 1988 contre la
criminalité il a fait une autre en 89
puis en quatre mois lancé sa grande loi
sur la criminalité en 94
il a été président de la commission de
justice du sénat donc c'est la question
qui connaît absolument parker en
revanche il a donné sur 7 sur cette
question une occasion en or par trump de
se re positionner vis-à-vis de ceux qui
ont peur légitimement peur parce que les
images sans quelques fois déroutante et
et font vraiment peur et donc ça a
permis à donald trump de se poser cette
question et ensuite ça lui a permis de
prolonger sur un soutien à la police et
aux pompiers qui est toujours une bonne
idée en campagne électorale
là dessus c'est vrai que qu'abidal était
bien démunie en rase campagne quand un
train est parti là dessus ça c'est sa
fortis et à des moments sentir le vent
et le prendre donc sur cette question je
dirais que sur le fond pour moi abbey
dawn était meilleure
mais sur la forme trump l'aï croisé il
ya un sujet important aussi qu'il faut
qu'on aborde avant de conclure cela il
maintient d'ailleurs je sais le saut
disappointed qui nous a rejoints sur
lefigaro.fr pas bien élever le niveau du
débat un sujet important c'est la
reconnaissance des résultats c'est un
thème qui fait souvent l'actualité
aux etats unis l'actualité qui qui
arrive même chez nous cette
reconnaissance des résultats de la
présidentielle américaine on va écouter
ce qui s'est dit sur le plateau
cette nuit entre les deux candidats pour
le voir ici nombre nombreux turcs averti
des histoires qui ne m'a jamais supporté
aka annabi président
extrait / bien la reconnaissance des
résultats c'est un thème qui avait déjà
été abordé lors des débats entre donald
trump et hillary clinton en 2016 alors
c'est peut-être habituel dans ces débats
entre candidats à la présidentielle vous
allez pouvoir m'éclairer jean eric
branaa mais en tout cas je voudrais
avoir votre réaction sur ce qu'on vient
d'entendre j'espère que ce sera une
élection équitable dit donald trump et
si je vois des dizaines de milliers de
bulletins de vote être manipulé je peux
pas être d'accord avec ça et puis on
parle ensuite on parle de on part on
passe de dizaines de milliers à 80
millions de bulletins de vote
on est un peu perdu dans tout ça est ce
que vous pouvez nous nous éclairer le
colon charlie un traitement je veux bien
vous répondre sur le fond je crois que
kristen va intervenir sur la forme parce
que c'est dans cette question là c'est
bien plus important encore que le fond
sur le fond pour être assez clair on est
en train de parler de vote de résultats
certifiés
c'est à dire qu'on est content et tout
le monde et qu'on sache réellement qui
est le président des états unis
alors il ya depuis une grande peur
l'idée qu'on aurait par le résultat
avant six mois et d'ailleurs
donald trump l'a évoqué tout à l'heure
ça veut pas dire qu'on va pas être sans
président pendant six mois
la constitution est très claire à ce
niveau-là ça si le vote ne se fait pas
le 3 novembre le vote se fait le premier
lundi après le deuxième mercredi 2
décembre c'est à dire le 14 décembre
c'est le collège électoral qui est
résident aux états unis c'est un vote
indirects et la constitution dit que n 1
bat du vote du 3 novembre la
constitution elle parle du vote du 14
décembre elle dit les grands électeurs
doivent être ce jour là dans leurs
capitales respectives pour voter pour le
président ce qui veut dire qu'au bout de
quarante-cinq jours après ce vote du 3
novembre
s'il n'y a pas les grands électeurs en
réalité au bout de 34 jours puisqu'il ya
une jurisprudence depuis bush contre
gaulle il faut que les grands électeurs
soit désigné par le gouverneur donc ils
le seront et ensuite il ya six jours
pour les contestations et ils se
réuniront normalement donc au bout de
quarante-cinq jours ils voteront pour le
président donc en réalité a pas de chaos
en réalité on c'est pour ça que je parle
je disais qu'ils avaient une question de
rhétorique parce que trump est très fort
pour enfumer tout le monde et nous
montrer un cadeau extraordinaire qui
que qu'abidal d'ailleurs a expliqué
comme moi en deux mots il a dit il va y
rien à voir particulier et la question
c'était parce qu'on reconnaît les votes
et lui il a répondu à cette question il
a dit moi je reconnaîtrais les résultats
quoi qu'il arrive le danger et c'est là
je vais si la parole à christophe sait
que trump a soufflé sur les braises et
donc il
il arme quasiment certains de ces
supporteurs et c'est ça qui nous fait
davantage peur je pense que je te casse
la formule du coup alors il est il est
indiscutable que d'un point de vue
strictement rhétorique sur cette affaire
et d'ailleurs c'est très ennuyeux pour
trame parce que c'est la fin du débat et
c'est donc très important
by dunn est beaucoup plus clair que le
message et la clarté du message quelle
que soit la période de la rhétorique
c'est toujours fondamentale donc la
trump père à mon avis un atout et
d'autant que le côté un peu menaçants
peut être totalement contre-productif
dans un pays quand même qui est un pays
profondément démocratique ne l'oublions
jamais sur des électeurs modérés ou
indécis j'aimerais bien savoir ce qu'ils
en pensent d'ailleurs ça peut avoir un
effet négatif
ils peuvent dire attendez moi on ne fait
pas de chantage à mon vote
on ne menace pas d'autant que
constitutionnellement les choses sont
assez claires ce qui est vrai jean-eric
c'est quand même la question du comptage
des votes puisqu'on avait vu avec la
floride
il ya 20 ans il peut y avoir ça peut
durer longtemps
la question du la certification d'un ou
de plusieurs états je crois quand même
une chose très importante
et là je parle sous votre contrôle va
être de savoir si le résultat va être
vraiment très étroit et et si un ou deux
saumons du swing states vont être
décisifs si la victoire de bail des
nénettes je pense que quoi qu'il en dise
drame se pliera ça peut ça peut en
revanche se discuter s'il ya vraiment un
problème de et comment dit on si on a un
résultat là 2016 est inversé c'est à
dire avec hayden gagnant par quelques
dizaines de mu milliers de voix dans
quelques swing states
jean eric branaa quand donald trump dit
vous avez 80 millions de bulletins de
vote ces gens ne sont pas équipés pour
gérer cela on parle de qui on parle de
quoi est ce qu'on parle des votes par
correspondance
alors il ya et tout ce qui est
l'élargissement du voc pose un problème
à donald trump
en réalité toutes les modélisations nous
montre aujourd'hui que s'il ya très peu
de participation
ça va avantager donald trump parce que
ceux qui n'iront pas voter c'est plutôt
des jeunes dont plutôt démocrate des
gens urbain plutôt démocrate également
ou ceux des banlieues
voilà alors c'est l'idée pour lui c'est
justement de décourager les gens de
voter il ya aussi ce fameux
découragement du vote vis-à-vis des
minorités
donc ils s'attaquent à tous ses
fondements ya pas que le vote par
correspondance qui lui pose problème il
ya par exemple dans certains états on
savait que le vote les états unis et à
votre complexe avec beaucoup de monde à
élire sur l'ombre pour le président
certes non vote aussi pour le sénateur
leur présentant le gouverneur pas mal de
postes les assemblées des états le
procureur le juge et en descendent
pareil dans les comtés pareil dans les
villes y compris pour les conseils des
écoles tout ça ça ce vote en même temps
et en plus des référendum dans certains
états et il y a dans certains états la
possibilité de cocher une seule case
démocrate et bohoun tous ceux qui se
sont déclarés démocrates sont élus enfin
pour vous c'est votre choix
et puis dans certains états c'est
interdit au texas ils ont décidé qu'il
fallait faire son choix alors ça peut
faire trente pages d'accès distant vote
très complexe et les délais les
républicains veulent garder ce système
pour avoir de plus de 2 des lui parce
que on peut choisir un président
démocrate mais un juge républicains
parce qu'on pense que sur la justice il
faut être un petit peu plus dur voilà
donc il essaie de complexifier un petit
peu le vote et donald trump est en train
de brouiller les pistes avec tout cela
et en même temps c'est en train de se
régler en amont puisqu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de procès qui sont en cours et
vocaux d'actions en justice etc les les
cours haddock les cours de l'élection
dans les différents états rappelons que
les élections sont organisées par les
états et non pas par l'état fédéral donc
ça se règle au niveau des états avec des
lois différentes données un autre et des
règles différentes d'un état à un autre
il ya un juge de l'élection qui peut
être la cour suprême est comme ça des
tas de communes langue ça peut être
quant aux checkpoints en face des
différentes cours qu'ils sont
désigné pour être le référent qui sont
en train de donner des solutions je vois
pas moi où il ya la place pour faire
recours devant la cour suprême dans
cette histoire là franchement je ne vois
pas le fondement mais je suis
certainement pas aussi bon juriste ou
ceux qui en toi
donald trump ils ont peut-être déjà
trouvé une faille dont je vous
personnellement je suis pas très inquiet
sur sur la suite je suis d'accord avec
christophe
si ça se joue à dix mille voix dans le
wisconsin à l'envers il y aura
évidemment comme un gros débat et et des
recomptages à n'en plus finir
ça c'est certain mais comme je parie
mois depuis un an sur une victoire
majeure pour les démocrates cette fois
ci à la reagan à l'envers je crois
qu'ils co n'aura pas ce problème là pour
aller pour élargir sa vous lirez géant
peut-être non je je je
tout va dépendre quand même moi je pense
que les débats contrairement à ce qu'on
dit souvent peuvent jouer surtout quand
les élections encore une façon sont
serrés et je rebondis sur ce qu'avait
dit jean eric et j'habite appelé les
internautes à s'y intéresser
le vrai débat qui va être intéressant si
le débat des vice présidents parce que
d'abord ils sont beaucoup plus calmes
comme style on va découvrir kamala
harris veux dire vraiment en france qui
à mon avis est peut-être le gros atout
aussi de la candidature démocrate et
surtout si elles ont des raisons de
santé
elle devient la première femme
présidente des états unis en tout cas il
y aura une attention particulière parce
que c'est pas n'importe laquelle vice
présidente ou n'importe laquelle le
candidat
donc je crois que ce sera très important
parce que je pense que le fonds sera
beaucoup plus abordés dans ce débat là
et il y aura beaucoup plus à un débat
politique au sens noble du terme qui va
à mon avis avoir un certain écho sur les
conséquences sur les autres débats
présidentiels
ça c'est le premier point pour ce qui
est de 2 du ii à l'autre comme jaillet
du résultat de l'élection
je ne sais pas si ce sera une victoire
colossal des démocrates
encore une fois je pense que les débats
jours
je pense que la situation sanitaire
jouera aussi et je pense que il y aura
une question de mobilisation des
électorats trump a rappelé une chose que
tu es assez habile et ça il faut pas
passer dessus c'est que une partie de
l'électorat noir on a assez des
désordres et des problèmes et de la
sécurité dans les centres villes où ils
sont nombreux et ça peut aussi
démobiliser une partie du camp démocrate
donc quand même il ya eu un petit
glissement est une inquiétude qui a été
attestée par les rendant la venue il ya
quand même eu pardon le soutien
suprématiste cette nuit qui annule tous
les effets vis-à-vis des noirs le
soutien oui il a refusé de condamner les
fans bros qui sont un groupe
suprémacistes blancs
d'accord ça on peut l'interpréter je je
je je crois pas qu'il ait dit qu'il
soutenait m'enfin ici il leur a dit mais
bon c'est pas rien quand même
allez il a repris leur force et sa
donald trump l'huile dans ses propos il
en tout cas condamné cibler les antifas
bien plus que les 6 mais voilà celui a
demandé si si condamner les
suprémacistes et il a commencé à le
faire et on fait ici
il est revenu en arrière son visage ses
cd forme et il a décidé finalement de ne
pas le faire je crois que c'est m le
plus commenté aujourd'hui aux états unis
ce qui s'est passé c'est intéressant
justement ce que l'audit jean-eric parce
que c'est une part importante de sa base
c'est suprémacistes alors tac étant
petit sa base mais elle ils font partie
de sa base mais c'est absolument pas le
plus important de sa base et c'est vrai
qu'on fait un amalgame très souvent
trump suprémacistes mais c'est vrai
qu'il était aussi entouré assez mal
entouré pendant sa dernière compagne il
était au plus proche de lui il y avait
des gens qui venaient du ku klux klan
delattre ait de différents groupes macif
2010 diverses et variées mais mais c'est
pas ça aujourd'hui sa base sa base c'est
yahia 3 3 blocs il ya quatre blocs
sébastien ce groupe là qui est assez
assez réduit et qui l'a gardé parce que
c'était des bons militants et quand en
réalité ça c'est sa campagne alors qu'il
n'avait aucune force en 2015 il y a des
gens qui ce qui souffrait ces fameux
blanc dont on parle laissés-pour-compte
de 2008 et qu'ils voulaient renverser le
la table à washington qui en avait marre
de la politique il ya les conservateurs
votent heureusement on a parlé dans
lequel on va mettre les évangéliques
bien sûr mais tous les conservatismes de
façon plus mike pence
il est là et il est là pour les les
représenter voyez là une base quand même
assez diverse et puis le mais les
républicains qui sont républicains et
qui veulent pas voter démocrate est qui
et qui ont trouvé que donald trump quand
même à aguerrir parti républicain de
cent son plus grand mal c'est un parti
divisé comme totalement fracture et
n'oublions pas c'était aussi il avait 17
candidats la dernière fois c'était un
parti à sémalens fois il a fait le
ménage alors de notre fenêtre et c'est
christophe le disait l attention des
états unis c'est pas la france donc
ne comparons pas des choses qui sont pas
comparables aux états unis les
républicains après si ça on se dit dans
la chef
le culte du chef est quand même très
fort dans ce parti voudrait qu'on
revienne sur ses propos au moment
d'évoquer les jets suprémacistes blancs
d'ailleurs on a leur à gond sur twitter
qui nous rappelle que les propos exacts
il a demandé aux pros de boys de se
tenir prêts elle belle jen qui nous
distingue bac en stand by
ces mots exacts qu'est ce qu'il faut
entendre par alain finalement la
question et pour qui ben jarry tôt
christophe si peut-être commencer par
christophe sur brian et moi j'ai pas à
manger je l'écoutais mois en à tort
d'ailleurs parce que je voulais être sûr
de ce que tu entendais je l'écouté avec
une traduction en français qui était
d'ailleurs moyenne je ne dirais pas sur
quelle chaîne donc ce qu' il faudra voir
le verbatim
le verbatim que ce passage de même que
je demanderai je reviens sur quelque
chose le verbatim sur les
responsabilités de trump dans le corona
et je maintiens que byden a été beaucoup
plus accusateur
dans ce débat je suis pas en général
dans ce débat que d'habitude mais c'est
un fait important en effet c'est
important si en effet le verbatim est
aussi clair moi j'ai entendu dire mais
j'ai peut-être j'ai peut-être malentendu
moi moi je n'ai rien pour laisser
primatice je suis plutôt content mais
dans cette affaire
dans cette affaire l'agitation vient
plutôt de des antilles fin voilà ce que
j'ai entendu mais je peux avoir mal
entendu ou entendu qu'une partie donc
nous avons des journalistes et nous
avons des internautes pour vérifier
verbatim exact où jean eric l'a
peut-être noté oui c'est ça ce destin du
bac en stand by
ce taux d'intérêt mais ça va et qu'est
ce qu'on doit entendre par là finalement
se tenir prêts à quoi jean eric branaa
c'est là justement tout le danger et
écouter ça renvoie aux propos de
christophe tout à l'heure c'est quand on
termine sur le menaçant au moment où on
a une réaction vis-à-vis des électeurs y
compris les lecteurs trappistes qui veut
pas qu'on lui vole son vote
d'ailleurs c'est c'est leur principale
revendication depuis quatre ans ils sont
six en colère c'est parce qu'on n'a pas
reconnu leur droit à la différence le
droit d'émettre un vote différent de du
mainstream qui étaient installés aux
etats unis ils disent enfin c'est ça la
démocratie et ils ont raison c'est c'est
d'ailleurs la base de la démocratie
donc si aujourd'hui ce président là leur
explique que on va aller dans l'autre
sens évidemment il va vers une réaction
et c'est un peu normal je parle pas de
tout groupe a mais 2 3% qui qui serait
même ça suffit
en vérité quand elle s'est aussi serré
et mais on sait pas ce qu'il a voulu
dire on sait pas moi je crois parce que
depuis que je pratique donald trump
je trouve que très souvent il se laisse
emporter dans sa tête vous savez souvent
il dit c'est l'ironie ou achat mais je
crois que réellement c'est le dire haut
niveau sa tête quand ils le disent et
des propos qui nous choque qui je crois
que il a de l'humour à la paix père j'ai
envie de dire humour des années 50
on aurait dit un moment à deux balles
bayetti qui passent pas aujourd'hui on
peut pas le faire mais lui c'est pas
qu'on peut pas le faire il s'est pas
adapté dans le changement d'humour est
en réalité on a la même chose là je
crois que ce qu'il a voulu dire c'est
comme en 2015 2016
ils sont là ils m'ont barras pas trop ce
sont des bons militants à portland y
sont allés pour nettoyer le truc donc ça
servait ma ma la diffusion de law and
order et c'était très bien ce qu'ils
voient pas c'est qu'en même temps ce
sont des gens qui ont des thèses qui
sont des tests de haine ils sont classés
comme groupe de n 1 aux états unis ce
couple a donc un président des états
unis à qui on demande que faites vous
avec l'encontre de haine il te tiens je
les condamne points et y a rien d'autre
à dire oui alors que quand on entend le
fait de deux de ces deux là en tout cas
cet appel à se tenir prêts on n'entend
rien de positif là-dedans un christophe
de voogd j'imagine ah ben c'est clair
que donc je suis entièrement d'accord
mais hélas il va falloir qu'il redresse
la barre ou que mike benchmark au
prochain débat et que mes sur cet enjeu
de la sécurité je maintiens que il a un
avantage est que la condamnation des
émeutes par baï donne était aussi très
très très modeste c'était très clair
discours depuis de peur de camp le
premier nommé chef a dit hier je pars on
parle du débat d'hier un pardon à bombay
non mais hier il peut pas parler c'était
du jeu hein
il n'a pas été absolument j'ai trouvé
encore une fois sur cette partie law and
order et c'est quand même un débat qui
qui était super combien de personnes
alors on parle de ce qui était annoncé
c'était une centaine de millions de
personnes normalement on a battu le
record mais j'ai pas des chiffres encore
passion c'est c'est c'est vraiment
fondamental dans ces cas-là ça c'est le
nouvel arrêt théorique si vous avez peu
de temps pour parler vous placez la
phrase comme il l'a très bien que sur le
résultat des élections vous casser la
phase décisive
moi je n'ai entendu très mou du genou
quand même sur cette affaire et on va
voir je pense qu'ils vont aussi les
démocrates vont devoir aussi préciser
leur position vis-à-vis des
manifestations je vous rappelle qu'il a
dit des manifestations pacifiques
ça ça ça ne passe pas il ya eu beaucoup
de manifestations non pacifiques et pas
seulement à portland
donc là je pense qu'il est par un
problème de crédibilité vis-à-vis de
l'électeur encore une fois qu'une seule
qui compte 1 celui qui se trouve là les
lecteurs entre les deux celui qui fait
l'élection
j'ai relevé le même problème je vais
vous remercier messieurs d'avoir pris le
temps d'être avec nous ce matin pour
débriefer ce premier des trois débats
entre les deux candidats à la
présidentielle américaine un donald
trump joe biden évidemment merci
beaucoup jean eric branaa d'avoir été
avec nous on vous retrouvera bien sûr un
tous les deux dans les semaines qui
viennent pour commenter pour analyser
cette campagne et la proche de ce
scrutin jean eric branaa maître de
conférences à paris ii et spécialistes
évidemment de la politique américaine
on reparle on remontre votre biographie
de joe biden qui sort très prochainement
le 7 octobre aux éditions nouveau monde
livre que vous pouvez d'ores et déjà
précommander et puis christophe de voogd
merci aussi d'avoir été avec nous
professeur agrégé d'histoire à sciences
po spécialiste de rhétorique politique
vous êtes également président du conseil
scientifique de la fondapol la fondation
pour l'innovation politique et je
mentionne votre dernière contribution
vos contributions démocratie sous
tension merci à toutes et à tous aussi
d'avoir été avec nous sur lefigaro.fr un
jean-paul nathan christian antilles pour
entre autres merci beaucoup d'avoir
animé le chat sur twitch aussi merci
pour toutes vos questions constructive
imparti raclée est l belgian ultra log
ou encore les mii merci aussi à toutes
celles et ceux qui étaient et bien levé
tôt pour nous poser des questions sur
youtube merci thales compte 70 e 2 s ou
encore monsieur c'est bien là écoutez
très bonne journée à toutes et à tous et
on se retrouve très vite pour de
nouvelles infos en direct et de nouveaux
débrief sur figaro live très bonne
journée
merci à vous merci à jean eric merci au
revoir